(audience cheering)
- Welcome to our show-
I know!
(audience cheering)
We're very excited.
I'm excited you're here
in person this time.
- Me too.
- Last time was over Zoom and I was so sad
'cause I love you.
So I was like wanting to meet-
You smell good, too.
Oh, I dunno what you're
wearing, but that's nice.
- Soap!
- Nice.
Whatever it is.
Hair product, whatever's going on.
It's very nice.
- And I'm your fan, too.
- Oh really?
Even if you're lying,
thank you.
- I'm not.
I remember you from back in the day.
Kelly and Guarini.
Team Kelly or Team Guarini.
I do.
I was there with a sign-.
- Did you vote for Justin,
is the question.
- I voted for you.
- Okay. (laughs)
I always ask. (laughs)
No, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Did you know though that
we are in the middle
of the Brenaissance?
Have you heard of this?
- I have.
- Your fans started it.
- I have heard of it.
- Okay, it's literally
blowing up everywhere.
Everyone keeps calling it the Brenaissance
which I think is amazing.
- And I think we're required
to look at the ceiling.
- Yes, to just admire art.
- Four-shortened images.
Renaissance images of
characters I played in movies.
- I'll do it.
- There's George of the Jungle
and he's sort of reaching
out, touching fingers with-
- With which one?
- Over there.
- How does it feel though?
People are like freaking out.
- It's nice to have
that recognition to be-
- Yeah, it's nice to work
really hard on something
and then have people recognize you for it.
- I agree.
- I love that.
So you're getting a lot
of love for "The Whale"
which is incredible.
But you just surprised fans, which-
(audience cheering)
It's incredible.
We're gonna get to that
'cause it's so incredible.
But I love this about you
'cause this says a lot
about your personality,
which means we could be friends
because you showed up
at a "Mummy" screening
dressed up as your character.
Is that true?
(Brendan laughs)
- Subliminally dressed?
- Yes, I love this.
- In inference.
- I love this.
- Oh right, this was in London.
- Did they freak out?
- Yeah, they made a lot of noise.
- I would've lost my mind.
- I tripped walking on
the stage practically
because I'm a klutz.
But it was wonderful.
They ran a double-header
of "The Mummy," "The Mummy Returns."
They projected it in 35
millimeter, glorious 35 millimeter.
- Oh, that's cool.
- And there were a lot of fans.
- And it was in Britain, right?
And that's where you actually
shot the movie, right?
- Part of it, yeah.
It was all in studio there
and it was also in Morocco.
But it was nice to go back
and say, "Hey, thanks for
making such a great movie."
- Yeah 'cause there's a couple.
So speaking of "The Mummy,"
is this the one that you almost died?
- Nearly... well, I was
choked out accidentally.
There's a hanging sequence.
- I know what you're
talking about, the sequence.
I didn't know that that actually happened.
- Well, I don't remember too.
Oh gosh, yeah.
- They tightened it so much that you-
(Brendan clears throat)
Like, what happened?
- I was standing on my
toes like this with a rope
and you only got so far to go.
- Yeah.
And Steve ran over and he said,
"Hey, it doesn't really
look like you're choking.
Can you...
sell it?"
And I'm like, all right, fine.
So I thought, one more take, man.
And the camera swooped around
and I went up on the toes
and the guy holding the rope above me,
he pulled it up a little higher
and I was stuck on my toes.
I had nowhere to go, but down.
And so he was pulling
up and I was going down.
And then the next thing I
knew, my elbow was in my ear.
The world was sideways and
there was gravel in my teeth.
And everyone was really quiet.
And there was a stunt
guy from the coordinator
was there and he was
going (hands clapping),
(softly) "Brendan"
(hands clapping) "Brendan, wake up."
And I'm like, "Oh, what, what happened?"
"Congratulations. You're in the club."
"Same thing happened to Mel
Gibson on 'Braveheart.'"
- Oh, my god.
- Thanks, I think.
I wanna go home!
- I love that he said Mel
Gibson in "Braveheart."
Was he like accidentally gutted?
- I think he was, yes.
Off to a blazing start
in this movie so far.
- Oh, my gosh.
That's scary.
I would've been like,
"The acting is fine,
I'm not choking for you."
So wait, I love this about you
because I'm not good at taking photographs
but you're into photography
and you're so amazing at it.
- Oh, thanks.
- Yeah, you have a great eye.
I got to see some of your work
and I wanna show everyone that.
But how did you get into it?
- I picked up a camera.
- Don't do that.
And you just were amazing at it.
- It was one of those
old Polaroid cameras,
the accordion ones and they sell packfilm.
Prolifically in the 90s.
And I wanted some instant gratification
and they gave these
really beautiful little
black and white images.
No negative and one-of-a-kind
kind of feelings.
That's how I started.
- I love that.
I love a polar-
I own like three different kinds.
I love Polaroids.
Well, okay, here's one.
So this photo, can you
tell us about this one?
- Oh, yeah.
I shot a film called "The Quiet American"
in Vietnam in 2001.
The story is that of an
American who goes to Vietnam
bringing foreign policy and aid.
And it's a controversial film
for its criticism of
American foreign policy,
blah, blah, blah.
But that meant that we
were the first production,
Western production in
Vietnam to shoot a film-
- Since?
- in forever.
And, that was in 2001.
But that meant because
it's a communist country
that the cops were always
following us around the place.
So we were infiltrated by Hanoi...
and these were the cops.
And they were always following us around
until one day I just went, "Hey, hi!"
And they just walked up and
started taking pictures.
So we end up making friends with them.
They're really nice guys, you know?
- I love the photo that you took,
even the ones where you could
just see the eyes in the back.
It's like each one has a story
that they're telling like with their eyes.
I love it.
It's really cool.
Yeah, nice shot.
Nice eye, I don't have that.
I'm so jealous.
- Just bring a camera with you.
It helps.
- I bring the camera, Brendan.
And it doesn't go out that way.
- Oh, If you look really closely.
That's Michael Caine.
And he was my scene
partner in the film also.
And that's a bunker.
There was a scene where
we were getting shelled
and it was very muddy and dug out.
And to keep myself from feeling
like I was going bonkers,
I started taking pictures of stuff.
And so anyway, that's Michael.
- Yeah.
- I think it's good to
have something to do
that's outside of your job, you know.
And capturing images is something
that is important to me.
- I quilt.
- Good for you.
- Not good at it, but I love doing it.
- Doesn't matter.
I'm an amateur enthusiast
with the camera anyway.
- I think it's awesome.
So since you were here a couple months ago
you got an Oscar nomination.
We knew it was gonna happen.
(audience cheering)
Everyone knew it was gonna happen.
How did you find out?
That's really cool news.
- Watching the broadcast at home.
In the morning, there was a
knock at the door of my bedroom
and my kids were there with balloons
and they had a Carvel ice cream cake.
- Oh my god, I will cry right now.
That's so sweet.
- It was Fudgie the Whale.
- Aw. Ice cream cakes are good.
- Oh, yes.
- Yeah.
- Enjoyed that one.
And now it's a core memory of mine.
- I love that.
Are you getting prepared for a speech?
Do you prepare speeches
or are you superstitious?
- Fail to prepare, prepare to fail.
- Oh, you know what, I'm the first one.
- I'm gonna put something in mind,
keep it behind glass with
a little hammer on it,
in case of emergency, break,
and then I'll be able to
thank all those people
that helped get me where I need to be.
- Speaking of words, you got
an amazing bowling trophy
that we replenished for you.
So has it found a really
cool place in your home?
- Yeah, it's actually in the
offices of A24 right now.
- Okay, perfect.
I just think it should go
right next to your Oscar.
- I'll have them send it on.
- I want you to put it right
next to the Oscar 'cause hmm.
So, this was interesting.
You worked with a dance
instructor for the role.
- Yeah, Beth Lewis is a dance instructor
who danced in Pilobolus company
for like seven or eight years.
Wonderful knowledge of the human body.
And because Charlie is created
with prosthetic makeup and appliances,
it was a cumbersome
costume, appropriately.
And to drive home the reality
of who he is and what it's
like to live with that
she would be in strict observation
of keeping a momentum to his every motion,
to teaching me how to
walk, observing gestures.
And it was very important
that we have such specificity
because up until now,
the use of this costuming
in films and makeup
has always been, to my mind,
in service of a mean joke
or to vilify a character.
And I don't think we need
to do that any longer.
So the rule with the
creation of him was that
the makeup should obey the
laws of physics and gravity.
Whereas before it had been, you know,
a fairly fit actor in a
costume that's a silhouette
that's filled with cotton
batting and you know,
your mind just goes, I'll
pretend I believe that,
but you really don't.
With this, it's seamless.
It had to be.
- It would change your
gait, like your walk,
everything about it.
- Everything.
And that was born of
paying close attention
to documentary footage,
to speaking to members
of the Obesity Action Coalition,
and observing all of the sensitivities.
And then most importantly, to my mind,
just forget about all the
gear that I was wearing
and just play the scenes.
Connect with my daughter.
Connect with Hong Chau
who's also nominated
for Best Supporting Actress in her role.
- That's awesome for you to mention that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have some footage of
you getting into character,
which is crazy.
- Oh, look at that.
- I mean, how long does this take?
- That morning, four hours.
- Oh, my god.
- Four hours and change.
So we would get there very early
but don't feel sad for me
because Adrien Moreau had
to get there before me
and he was always the last boots to leave
at the end of the day.
Oh, there I am sleeping.
Yes, it's probably like about six o'clock
in the morning now.
They woke me up.
Someone gave me a smoothie.
- Someone gimme a smoothie.
It's like so quick. (laughs)
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, so let's see how all
of that work came together.
Here's Brendan Fraser
in his Oscar-nominated
role in "The Whale."
- I need to know that she's
just gonna have a decent life
where she cares about people
and other people care about her
and she's gonna be okay.
- I need to go.
- She doesn't-
- I have to go.
- have anyone else.
I need to know that I
have done one day right
with my life.
- I can't...
(audience applauds)
What?
Like, I've seen it and it still gets me.
That's... okay.
I just need a minute.
Look-
I'll get all this makeup on.
This isn't real.
(laughs)
You're so kind.
- I gotta prepare.
Q&A Sessions and question, answers.
After-screenings of this,
people feel that they have
really gone through something
- It doesn't even matter
how much you see it.
It's so good.
Brendan, it's so believable, it hurts.
It's fine.
"The Whale" is in theaters
and on demand now.
Go see it.
Especially feel like a good cry.